I'm speaking now specifically of
Christians. All right? So, in the case
of the New Zealand Christchurch mosque
attack, the Australian fellow, he killed
the 51 Muslims in their mosque.
Horrible. Now, brace yourself for a
small list that I compiled sometime
back, and it's actually not up to date,
but you'll get the point of what Muslims
have done to Christians in their places
of worship. Now, I'm not even talking
about Muslims just randomly killing
Christians in any kind of I'm talking
about I'm trying to get you a sort of
tit-for-tat, which means okay, you have
an you have an example of a non-Muslim
entering mosques and killing worshipers.
So, now let me give you an example of
Muslims entering churches and killing
Christians. And then we're going to I
think as I give you these examples, you
might start seeing where I'm going with
this. Again, this is this is a random
list, but I'm going to try to go through
it real quick. Sri Lanka, April 2018, on
Easter Sunday, Muslim terrorists bombed
three churches and three and three
hotels. In the end, 359 people, mostly
Christians, are killed. 500 injured. A
lot bigger than killing 51 Muslims in
two mosques, isn't it? All right, let's
continue. Nigeria, April 20, 2014,
Easter Sunday, Muslim terrorists torch a
a packed church. 150 Christians burned
alive. Pakistan, March 2016, following
Easter Sunday services, Muslim
terrorists bomb a park where Christians
had congregated after church. More than
70, mostly women and children, killed.
"There was human flesh on the walls of
our house," recalled a witness.
Democratic Republic of Congo Congo,
February 2025, kind of recent. Muslim
militants uh rounded up and marched 70
Christians to a church, tied them up,
and decapitated all of them with knives.
Iraq, October 31, 20 2011.
Muslims stormed a church in Baghdad
during worship, open fire
indiscriminately before detonating their
suicide vests, killing and being killed
in the in the words of the Quran. Nearly
60 Christian 60 Christians, mostly
women, children, and some babies were
killed. Nigeria, April 8, 2020 2012,
Easter Sunday. Explosives planted by
Muslims are blown up near two churches.
More than 50 Christians killed. Nigeria,
June 5, 2022, Pentecost Sunday. Muslims
open fire on a packed church, killing
more than 50. Egypt, April 9, 2017, Palm
Sunday. Muslims bomb two very packed
churches. At least 45 Christians are
killed, more than 100 injured.
Nigeria again, December 25, Christmas,
2011. During Christmas Day services,
Muslim terrorists shoot up and bomb
three churches. 37 people killed, nearly
nearly 37 injured. Egypt, December 11,
2016. Islamic suicide bombing of two
churches leaves 29 people killed, 47
injured.
Burkina Faso, African nation, August
2024. Muslim militants slit the throats
of 26 Christians inside their church,
peacefully worshiping. Syria, this is a
recent one kind of, on June in June
2025, Muslims murdered 25 Christians,
again, mostly women and children, and
wounded nearly 100 inside a Damascus
church.
According to eyewitnesses, one or two
armed Muslim the one or two armed men,
Muslims, entered the Mar Elias Greek
Orthodox Church in Damascus during mass
when it was packed with about 350
people, and they indiscriminately opened
fire before detonating an explosive
inside the sanctuary.
Like other examples I just gave, "When
we got to the church, we found the
doorway uh filled with body parts," said
a relief helper who arrived soon after
the attack.
Photos showed charred
and blood-splattered floors with
shrapnel peppering the church walls.
Russia, June 2024. Muslim terrorists
launch attacks on several churches and
synagogues in the Muslim region of
Dagestan. At least 21 people were
killed, dozens wounded. Terrorists
yelling Allahu Akbar slit the throat of
an elderly and ailing Orthodox priest in
one of these attacks and at least one
church was set a flame. Nigeria, again,
April 20, 2012. Muslims slaughter 20
Christians inside their church during
Sunday worship. Democratic Republic of
Congo, January 2023. Muslims bomb a
church during a Sunday baptismal
ceremony. At least 14 Christians were
blown to pieces
and the Islamic State claimed the
attack, said that 20 to 63 others were
actually wounded. Indonesia, May 2018.
Muslims bomb three churches. 13
Christians were killed and dozens
injured. Egypt, January 1st, 2011.
Muslim terrorists bomb an Alexandrian
church during New Year's Eve mass. 21
Christians killed.
In the words of one eyewitness, body
parts were strewn all over the street
outside and were brought inside the
church after some Muslims started
stepping on them and chanting chance
like Allahu Akbar.
So, after the Christians were blown up
out of their church, random Muslim
passersby stomped on the dead parts
screaming Allahu Akbar.
Philippines, January 2019. Muslim
terrorists bomb a cathedral. At least 20
Christians were killed, more than 100
injured. Indonesia, December 24, 2000.
During Christmas Eve services, Muslim
terrorists bomb several churches. 18
killed, over 100 injured. Burkina Faso,
again, February 2024. Muslim gunmen
storm a Catholic church during service,
open fire, murder 15 Christians.
Pakistan, March 15, 2015. Muslim suicide
bombers kill at least 14 Christians in
attacks on two churches. Germany,
December 19th, 2016, near the Kaiser
Wilhelm Memorial Church in Berlin, a
Muslim man drove a truck into a
Christmas market. 13 are killed, 53
injured. Egypt again, December 29th,
2017, Muslim gunmen shot up a church in
Cairo. Nine Christians were killed.
Egypt, January 6th, 2010, following
Christmas Eve mass, according to to the
Orthodox calendar, Muslim shoot up shot
six Christians dead as they were leaving
their church after celebrating
Christmas. Russia again, February 18th,
2018, a Muslim man carrying a knife and
a double double-barreled shotgun enters
a church, opens fire. Five people, all
women, are killed. At least five more
are injured.
France, July 2016, Muslims entered a
church and slit the throat of the
officiating priest, 84-year-old Father
Jacques Hamel,
and took four nuns hostage until French
authorities managed to kill the
terrorists.
Turkey, January 2024, two masked gunmen
entered a Catholic church and opened
fire. One man was killed, another
injured. Surveillance footage showed the
rest of the 40 or so congregants running
away in panic.
Okay. Now, um, we have all this compared
to what happened in New Zealand, which
got its own day and which we're all
talking about right now.
Now, this list that I just gave you is
hardly comprehensive. In Nigeria alone,
where one Christian is slaughtered every
2 hours, look it up,
by Muslims,
Muslims have destroyed or torched some
20,000 churches and Christian schools.
And I don't know how many undocumented
souls were
died and perished in those torchings.
But because Nigeria doesn't matter,
those black lives don't matter cuz
they're Christian, you won't hear about
what's happening in Nigeria, which I'm
going to talk about a little bit some
more.
Nor does a list that I just gave you
include all the botched terrorist attack
attempts on churches. There are so many
all the time where actually the
terrorists men don't get it right, the
bomb doesn't work, they get arrested
beforehand.
For example, in
there was an attack on another
Indonesian church during Palm Sunday.
In this in 2021 and the only people that
died were the suicide bombers. A Muslim
man and his pregnant wife.
Closer to home and more recent still,
according to an October 2025 report,
Alexander Scott Mercurio, an 18-year-old
convert to Islam, was arrested in Coeur
d'Alene, Idaho for quote, planning a
suicide attack on multiple churches.
According to the report, quote, law
enforcement claims that he was going to
attack local places of worship with
knives, guns, and flame. Nor again does
the list that I just rattled off here
include all the daily non-fatal attacks
on European churches. Okay, the
desecration. Constant non-stop daily.
This
feces smeared on churches, urine,
churches being lit on fire, catching
fire as they say, and of course the
media goes out of its way to tell you,
oh, it's just who who could who could
possibly be doing this? It must be an
accident, right? You know, to be fair, I
I follow this very closely and once in a
while you'll see who the culprit is.
They'll be described as a North
African-looking man or an Asian man,
okay? Or sometimes you will know it's a
Muslim and they capture him and his name
is Muhammad or something. But having
said that, because of the frequency of
attacks on churches all throughout
Europe, I don't think it's all just
Muslims. It's their allies, you know,
the left, okay? And all its
manifestations, to be sure. This is why
in Canada churches are are set a flame
all the time. It's not so much Muslims,
actually. It's lunatic lefties,
um the woke crowd. But having said that,
I I know for a fact Muslims are also
involved and probably have the lion's
share, I would I would think, of all the
attacks.
In France alone, I think two you can
look it up, two churches are attacked
every single day, desecrated. It's so
common and and people are so
desensitized it doesn't make the news.
That's my point.
If this were to happen to a mosque, it'd
be all over the news and it would be
called Islamophobia. But because it's
happening to churches, well, it doesn't
really matter, does it? And nobody cares
and we're all desensitized by now.
Now,
>> [clears throat]
>> based on that list that I just gave you
of all those bombings and churches and
how many people Christians died,
if you add it up, it's something like at
least a thousand Christians, at least,
okay, who were peacefully worshipping in
their churches until Muslims walked in
and killed them and bombed themselves
and whatnot. Just like what happened in
the the two mosques in New Zealand,
right? Same exact scenario. Now, here's
the pressing question for everyone at
the UN. If one non-Muslim attack,
which claimed 51 Muslim lives, was
enough for the UN to establish an
International Day to combat
Islamophobia,
why have countless Muslim attacks on
churches not been enough for the UN to
establish, say, an International Day to
combat Christianophobia?
This hasn't even been mentioned. Every
single one of these attacks that I told
you, if any official from the UN or
related bodies were to even acknowledge
them, he would go out of his way to tell
you this has nothing to do with the
religion. This isn't about This isn't
Islam. This is just criminals, random
criminals. They may be screaming Allahu
Akbar and reading the Quran and quoting
it and saying, "Let's kill infidels."
It has nothing to do with the religion
whatsoever, okay? There's nothing to see
here, move on. It's all about what
happened at in New Zealand, okay?
New Zealand, what would you say, 51
Muslims were killed?
The examples that I gave you, which are
just again, this is a sampling. This is
by not in any way, shape or form
reflective of how many Christians have
been killed at the hands of Muslims in
recent years. But I gave you a thousand
Christians peacefully worshipping in
their churches, butchered and massacred
and blown away by Muslims.
No word, no Christianophobia, no day to
combat it, no nothing like that.
Instead, we have a day to shut you up
from talking about this and we call it
Islamophobia, okay? Which means you
better shut up and not mention any of
this because we don't want this around
ruining our agenda, okay? Which
includes, of course, sending Muslims
into your country to take over. And kill
you and get you evicted and basically
demographically take over as they are
and already have in a lot of Western
European countries, the UK foremost
among them. And really, you know, this
question becomes even more pressing when
one realizes that whereas the New New
Zealand mosque attack
was indeed an aberration. How often do
you hear about that? That's some
non-Muslim enters a mosque and kills all
the Muslims. It's not a very common
thing, okay? Not at all. But what I just
told you, Muslims attacking Christian
churches, that's a common thing. It's
almost like I and we're going to get
into it. But it's a very, very common
thing. It happens every month I come
across several examples of serious
attacks. And it could be from the
government authorities just randomly
shutting it down, could be terrorists
bombing it, could be a mob angry about
this, that, or the other thing burning
it down.
Um it could be any number of things, but
there's so many examples of that.
So isn't it interesting
that the UN takes the aberration which
is Muslim non-Muslims attacking Muslims
in their mosque and killing them. And
they turn that into the rule which we
all now have to stand in awe of and you
know, commemorate Islamophobia Day. But
then, the common thing that's happening
constantly, which is Muslims attacking
churches
and killing them, that it's not a real
thing. It's not even happening. And it's
even more telling when you realize that
all of the examples that I gave you of
Muslims attacking churches, Christian
churches,
um where do they come from? Where do
they Is it what Is it localized to one
country or one region? No. As you saw,
they came from Nigeria and Iraq and the
Philippines and Egypt and Iran and Syria
and Turkey. They come from all over. And
the people who commit them, they're of
different races. They're Asian, Middle
Eastern, Arab, uh
Turkish, Iranian, African.
And they speak different languages and
they live under different governments
and socio-economic conditions.
So, what's the only thing that binds
them together? Well, it's that thing
called Islam.
>> [laughter]
>> Which,
unshockingly, teaches hostility for
churches actually and infidels.
All right? So, it all makes perfect
sense, except the machinery all around
you doesn't want you to know it.
All right? So, on [clears throat] the
one hand, we have an aberration, a
non-Muslim does what he did, and that is
the story and we have to establish dates
and and we have to talk about this.
But when Muslims of all nations,
ethnicities, and races, and languages,
and backgrounds
do the same thing and posit it as a
religious thing by talking about Islam
and jihad and infidels, yeah, there's
nothing to see here.
There's no combat Christianophobia day.
There's no anything, really, because
it's just it's just criminality. We're
not worried about it, right?
You see how that works?
All right.
So, to underscore what I just said,
Muslim attacks on churches are
ideologically driven. This is a fact.
They have been and continue to be
systematic and systemic and are
therefore an actual ongoing problem that
the so-called international community
should acknowledge and try to highlight
and ameliorate.
But they're not. The UN would rather
ignore and not look at any of that that
I just mentioned, all those attacks on
Christians which just are if they get
any mention in in um in the media, you
know, the Muslim identity of the killers
is completely expunged. They're They're
just terrorists and evildoers. Sometimes
even the Christian identity of those
killed, you won't even know what
happened. It'll be an attack on some
people who were killed and uh you scroll
all the way down to the end of the
report, you realize, "Oh, it was in a
church and the people killed were
Christians." And then you scroll some
more and oh, the attackers were Muslims.
Okay. And then they tell you it was
because of, you know, climate change
pushed one group to attack the other.
But it has nothing to do with Islam,
just to be clear. All right? That's what
they'll tell you.
So, we're supposed to ignore all that.
That's not real and let's focus on
what's happening with what happened in
New Zealand, that one aberration. Okay?
Becau- Why? Because that one aberration
gave them what they want, the excuse to
shut down free speech on Islam in this
case. And that's exactly what
Islamophobia is. What's that word mean?
I told you it's fear of Islam, but they
want you to treat it it's a sickness.
You have an irrational fear that doesn't
make sense and we got to we got to, you
know, fix you. But
uh But all that stuff that Muslims do,
their doctrine, their books, their
history, current events, yeah, that's
just you're crazy. It's not really
happening. It has nothing to do with the
religion. So, what if they stand and
quote the Quran and say Allah Akbar and,
you know, Muhammad commands us to do
this like like the um ambassador told
Thomas Jefferson. So, what? You know,
you're you're you're misunderstanding.
You're an Islamophobe. A brain
attack the
Bring the
Bring back
the fire
>> [music]
>> and the righteous